they did last year the G7 foreign
ministers come together for their
meeting against the background of
Russia's war in Ukraine with the U.S
wanting to demonstrate a united front
with its allies so we are going to see
the Fortified security and economy
partnership based upon common values and
principle led by the United States as
well as a specific road maps to deal
with the new phase of the war in Ukraine
as well as the the response to the
coordination and cooperation between
Moscow and Beijing after the recent
visit by China's president Xi Jinping to
Russia there are lingering fears Beijing
might give more material support to
Moscow especially if it feels the U.S
and its allies are pushing too hard to
constrain its Growing Power this
Gathering also takes place in the
aftermath of what North Korea claims was
the successful launch of its most
sophisticated intercontinental ballistic
missile to date that briefly triggered
situation alarms in the northern
Japanese island of Hokkaido as the only
Asian G7 country Japan finds itself
uniquely positioned on the front lines
of current Global crises as a neighbor
of China Russia and North Korea and its
presidency of this year's G7 comes as it
takes a more assertive International
role moving away from the traditional
pacifism of the post-world War II era
Japanese warships took part in
trilateral drills with U.S and South
Korean navies last month and Tokyo plans
to double its defense spending in the
coming years
Japan's pacifism is well established I
believe however countries like North
Korea China and Russia pose a threat to
Japan and Japan is directly confronting
these countries military forces it is
not Japan that is raising the threat but
the surrounding authoritarian regimes
and dictatorships
with concerns the strains of War are
testing the unity of G7 members the U.S
attempts to get its allies to hold the
line will be fully supported by a
Japanese Administration Marching In
lockstep Rob McBride Al Jazeera
karuizawa Japan